All right, everybody, let's hope. Let's really
hope that these are the final Trump rally
clips that I will ever be bringing you.
Now we are in the final stretch. Donald
Trump did rallies yesterday in Florida, North
Carolina, Pennsylvania, Michigan and Wisconsin.
The election is today, but there have been
rumors that Trump is looking at continuing
to do rallies later this week. If the results
aren't yet final. But let's hope that doesn't
happen. And let's hope these are the rat last
rallies ever. Let's look at a few clips, just a
smattering of the tone and tenor of the last day
of the campaign for Donald Trump. Donald Trump
shouting out musician Ted Nugent, who previously
threatened to kill Barack Obama and predicted that
by April of. Was it twenty, fourteen, if Obama.
No, by April of 2013, if Obama won in 2012,
Nugent would be dead or in jail. Neither was true.
Here's Trump shouting about Ted Nugent and his.
Great job that he's been from day one, right?
Great job. Thank you very much. I appreciate
the love. I love your sound. I love your music.
And speaking of Donald Trump then threatening
well in the state of Michigan to never return
to the state of Michigan if he loses today.
Thank you very much. Look, you can't
let this happen to our country, OK?
We know what's going on.
You can't let this this was a total fluke.
This was a total fluke in
primetime. It didn't work and now
it's not working. What a disaster. I
can't believe this is even happening.
It puts much more pressure on me running
against a guy like this, Jonah. You know,
you lost somebody. That was good. Can you
imagine if the concept of losing this guy.
Oh, you better you better get out
there and vote tomorrow. UCLA.
Interesting tone, sort of more of a grievance
tone than a powerful tone. Trump here telling the
crowd, You're so lucky that I agreed to be the
president of the United States. Humble, right?
You are so lucky.
I've agreed to be your president.
Go out and vote for Trump.
And then Donald Trump describing
himself as maybe maybe the most innocent
person in the history of the United States.
Yes, there were vicious. They were smart if they
could find any little morsel. And they went over
taxes and they went over everything you can go
over. They spent 40 a million dollars, two and
a half years. The Mueller investigation scam.
And they come up. No collusion. There's
no collusion after all of that. Which
makes me perhaps the most innocent man
anywhere in the history of the United States.
Now, this actually relates to our next topic
today, Trump's innocence. But I don't want
to get ahead of myself. So let's continue.
Donald Trump then making the case the not the
case. Just saying that Joe Biden is against God.
He's against oil. Oil. Is it good if you're
against oil and all that? Good. Good.
That's good politics. Right. And he's against God.
Now, I've mentioned this before. I don't care
about religiosity when I look at a candidate.
Them being religious or not. What I care
about is policy. I don't need a religious
candidate not being someone religious myself.
It just so happens that Joe Biden is actually
the religious candidate here. Donald
Trump claiming to have found religion
when he decided to run for president.
Joe Biden actually is a devout Catholic.
It doesn't make Joe Biden appeal to me anymore.
But that's the reality. The glitches keep coming.
Just one hear Trump trying to say corrupt glitches
and says corrupt. And then you see that spasm.
In 2016, Wisconsin voted to fire this
crap. And really, it's like corrupt,
corrupt political establishment. Right.
And you elected an outsider as president.
And then, of course, Donald Trump
continuing to promise that the
Corona virus vaccine will be available. Now,
what's a couple of weeks now? Unfortunately,
the fact that Trump says a couple of weeks makes
me think it could be months. But recall that
Donald Trump said we would have 100 million doses
of the vaccine by the end of October of this year.
It's now November. Donald Trump also promising in
July and August that we were two weeks away from
him signing a new health care bill into law.
Neither has happened. Take a listen to this.
This election is also a choice between a
deadly Biden lockdown or a safe vaccine.
The vaccine is coming along great.
A couple of weeks, couple of weeks.
It's going to be out soon. That ends the pandemic
and it will end anyway. They hate it when I say
we're around the corner. It's going to end anyway.
But the vaccine will make it go a lot quicker.
And what we've done with
therapeutics is incredible.
And then this next one I love, this is at
a different rally. Trump attempting to talk
about beyond saying Jayce, Jay-Z. He says, Now
I'm confusing myself because of Trump's glitch.
Trying to talk about Beyonce and Jay-Z. Trump
talks about Beyonce C, which I just love.
They got Beyonce C and they
got Jay-Z. Right, Jay-Z.
And he started using the F word, you remember,
in front of this graph, and it was umble and he
was using the F word F for an affluent crowd.
You can't use that effort, guys. That I mean,
Trump uses it, of course. But when when a
rappers use it, when R and B artists use it,
it's very, very bad. And then here's Trump
without any indication that he recognizes how
stupid what he's saying is. He says Republicans
are disadvantaged by the Electoral College.
We're going to get New Hampshire and
we're going to get New Hampshire. Yeah.
Yeah. New York. Can you believe that? Ceded
the decision. The disadvantage we have
the disadvantage we have, because I think in
certain ways you campaigned totally differently.
The disadvantage we have with the Electoral
College, you automatically lose automatically.
If you bring back Abraham Lincoln and George
Washington as his running mate, you lose
New York, Illinois and California.
Now, as I'm sure you know, were it not
for the Electoral College. We would have had fewer
Republican presidents. Many Republican candidates
have been bailed out by the Electoral
College. Then Trump will say, well,
with a national popular vote, we'd run
a different campaign. OK. But that's a
totally different argument. And then the last
moment, it's November of 2020. Donald Trump
is still talking about Hillary Clinton
as his followers yell, lock her up.
Thirty four states against a crooked person, a
very crooked person. How crooked is. By the way,
how crooked is Hillary? She deleted
33000 e-mails. What's happening with.
But we won. We won.
We won like nobody's nobody's ever won,
like we've won. Know the likes of which nobody is.
We must end this. We have to stop this.
And part of why Donald Trump is behaving this way
is that he's scared. Let's talk about that next.